let's think about how many blocks we
have here or what number this these
blocks represent
well i have four groups of a hundred
here so i could say that i have four
hundreds
four hundreds
i have three groups of ten here so i
could write plus three tens
plus
three tens and then i have six ones here
so i could write plus six ones
plus six
ones and so i can write that as
i could write that as i could write a
six in the ones place for my six ones
three in the tens place for my three
tens
for my three tens and then a four in the
hundreds place for my
four hundredths so this is 436 436
436. now let's subtract from that
let's subtract from that
let's subtract from that
the number
the number 300
312
312 and let's think about what we would
do here for subtracting 300 if we are
subtracting
312.
well we had six ones before we're taking
away two ones so let me write that down
we're going to take away
two
ones
we're taking away one ten
so we're taking away one ten so minus
one
ten
and we're taking away three hundreds
so we're taking away so we're taking
away three
hundreds
three hundreds so what's that going to
do to us what's that going to do to us
well we had four hundreds we're taking
away three hundred so let's take them
away let's take away
let's take away
the
let's take away the
one
two
and three hundreds and we're just left
with one hundred one
hundred we could do it over here four
hundreds take minus four hundreds minus
three hundreds is going to be one
hundred
now we had
three tens we're taking away one ten so
let's do that
so we're going to be left with two tens
so plus two
tens three minus one is two three minus
one is two
and then
last then we have six we had six ones
we're taking away two ones
and we're going to be left with four
ones six minus two is four
six minus two is 4 and we're done
436 minus 312 is 124 and you see how we
did that we took away three hundreds we
took away 110 and we took away
two
ones to get 124
which is 100 two tens and four ones